wo ist dein weg
das ist die adresse und die
telefonnummer
ich kenne die adresse ich komme morgen
mit das ist super und gehst du ich habe
gleich ein bewerbungsgespräch
was ist dein beruf aber du hast du dich
als lehrerin
doch ich bin lehrerin für deutsch und
englisch aber ich habe keine feste
arbeit an einer schule und die
sprachkurse die sprachkurse sind nur
einen nebenjob ich jetzt brauche ich
eine wichtige arbeit wieder viel glück
aber bist du schon recht gut findest du
möchtest du auch lehrer werden meine
eltern sagen ingenieur ist gut und du
ich war lange in einer bank ich bin
bankkaufmann
das verstehe ich nicht du hast auch ein
restaurant stimmt zusammen tarek tarek
ist eigentlich elektriker vom beruf
warum
naja wir finden die arbeit im restaurant
interessant es macht spaß und jedem tag
gelegt die chefs der arbeit ist also
gerne im restaurant ja ich mag meine
arbeit und tarik auch oder tabak
mein job und du findest du schon eine
gute arbeit